do you get like a an abandonment at all
do you feel like oh [ __ ] he can't leave
me do you get attached oh yeah I totally
and it wasn't I always on an
intellectual level I want I really do
want people I've worked with to thrive
and my dream has always been and it's
kind of come true that a bunch of people
that work with me go on they do really
cool things they create shows they do
stuff and then later on 10 years from
now when I'm just happy to get anything
they call me up and say hey do you want
to do a walk on them a really cool
project uh great I want my friends to
thrive almost in self-interest you know
I I the way Sid Caesar had all these
amazing people around him I always
thought that would be great I want that
but yes I got really uh very attached to
people
certain people and
um when Andy Richter he took out like a
long Hiatus from our show I was
devastated just because I loved the guy
I love the guy and he's so funny and he
was such an integral part of the show do
you let a guy like Andy know Conan that
you're devastated or do you try to just
keep up her lip and act like you don't
need him you know well he knew I needed
myself there was no that wasn't going to
work
um I do I would say I lean more to the
other way because I if someone comes to
me and says look I want to move on I
want to do this other thing it's putting
too much on them if I say this
devastates me I really miss you and this
is hurting me so
um I didn't do that with Andy uh and I
mean I let him know he knows I love him
and uh I'm I I've told Andy I love you
more times than I've told my wife
foreign